[Aplausos]
sabían que más de 200 años nos ha
costado a nosotras las mujeres chilenas
conseguir un lugar en la sociedad fuera
de las puertas de nuestras casas tan
solo por ser mujer existe un término que
se llaman la selín barriers el glass en
invadir significa techo de cristal este
techo de cristal se le impiden
independientemente a las mujeres
trabajadoras
avanzar salir adelante marcar con una
diferencia en la base de un barril se
apareció
en 10 años antes que yo naciera en 1986
en un artículo del wall street journal
en los eeuu
este techo se refiere a las barreras
invisibles que se les impida la matriz
trabajadora como ya les había dicho
y salir adelante
avanzar marcar ver una diferencia
este hecho también se les impide
independientemente de sus esfuerzos y
logros imagínense mujer
síndrome de dawn doble discriminación
las mujeres luchamos por mucho tiempo
para ser consideradas ciudadanas sujetas
de derecho como por ejemplo en derecho a
votar el derecho a la educación superior
el derecho a tener un título profesional
me frente a muchas barreras la mayor de
ellas era hacia mi diagnóstico dicen que
los down son o no estamos preparados
para el síndrome de dawn
mis padres no sabían nada pero no andan
haciéndome de down
yo soy su primera hija de tres hermanas
muy orgullosamente de ella
ellos creyeron en mi persona
buscaron un colegio con un proyecto
educativo inclusivo que apostará en la
diferencia como un valor
ellos mis padres también tuvieron un
trato igualitario con las 3
en mi colegio tuve los mismos ramos que
mis compañeros tuve matemática química
física deporte lenguaje arte inglés
y el mismo el aprendizaje a veces era
más lento los contenidos eran los mismos
y los profesores me hacían las
adecuaciones para que no se para que
usted no sé si saben si no saben qué son
las adecuaciones son guías adaptadas
los contenidos eran los mismos que los
compañeros pero eran adaptadas a mi
ritmo de aprendizaje que era más lento
te aseguro que los especialistas de
apoyo no fueron especialistas en el down
porque eso yo me ponía un techo
sin barniz se cuidan
ella aseguró que los especialistas
fueran de educación y que creyeran en mi
persona
y para qué hablar de educación superior
y ser profesionales pareciera que la
educación superior y ser profesionales
el síndrome de dawn
en la educación superior fuera como
plantear humanos en marte
primer semestre de locución ramo or
teología
y ya recuerde
estas que me dictó rimas sonoras cultas
y aunque bucólica thalía o excelso ponte
en las purpúreas tórax que cruces el
alma nos escribe el día ahora que de
toulouse tony habladoras escucha al sol
de la campaña mía si ya los numerosos
deben de vuelva a tener el viento fatiga
la selva templado por el lama de esa
mano el generoso pájaro su pluma otan
modelar caldera y en vano aún desmentir
al que es cabal presuma rascando haga el
freno de oro cano al caballo andaluz es
esta espuma quien va le abriera el
cordón de seda y al cuerno al fin
etcétera suceda pero hacer ejercicios
sean robustos o si atento silencio dulce
en cuanto debajo escuchas el corcel a
gusto de músicos hallan esfero canto
alternas con las musas soy un gusto que
si lo mío puede ofrecer tanto clarín y
de la fama no segundo tu nombre irán los
términos del mundo
esta fábula es una fábula de polifemo y
galatea cosa que las palabras eran super
extrañas pero les cuento algo
fue demasiado difícil porque tuve ganas
de arrancar
lo increíble no es que yo me haya
aprendido esto lo increíble
que yo tenga que hacer una demostración
para que ustedes empiecen a creer en
nosotros
pero claro los down tenemos mala memoria
entonces la educación superior ni hablar
las personas con síndrome de dawn
también somos todas diferentes
tenemos distintos ritmos requerimos de
distintos apoyos y cada uno
entrega su valor
pero no falta el profesor que dice
para que va a estudiar para que lo vamos
a evaluar si es down que sea feliz
para nosotros no es muy diferente hacen
feliz para ustedes ser feliz tiene
relación con sentirse querido
pero no sólo esto con esto no alcanza no
alcanza con sentirse querido para ser
feliz
cierto
ser feliz para todas las personas
significa también a veces están de
acuerdo conmigo contar con educación de
calidad contar con trabajo sí o no
sentirse útil
salud contando salud y vivienda contar
con una vida independiente elegir y ser
autónomo
de tener espacios de ocio tener amigos
ser escuchado salir de carrete tumbar de
vez en cuando un benito de una cervecita
dos barreras todo el rato
les voy a poner otro ejemplo cuando voy
a un restaurant con mi familia
él garzón en vez de decirme a mí le dice
a mi mamá
si niñita que eres pollo con papas
fritas
y yo les digo el verso caballero venga
manga
a mí me gusta la comida gourmet
a mí me traiga me por favor un cebichito
con un pisco sour
bien pudo barrer a todo el rato es
fantástico
la gente piensa que porque tenemos
síndrome de down somos todos iguales uno
de los principales mitos y eso no es así
es cuando por ejemplo voy por la calle
con una mano sola me detienen los
detiene en una fiesta yo tengo un igual
aquí estamos reforzando el sol todos
somos iguales
y yo les digo querrás decir tu hijo o
hija tiene el síndrome de down
y me responden de vuelta si mi hijo o
hija tiene síndrome de down
todas las personas somos diferentes
y ahí está el valor el valor de la
diferencia cada uno aporta con lo suyo
necesitamos más oportunidades y que
crean en nosotros y es verdad hoy en día
hay más oportunidades con la ley de
inclusión
pero saben lo que pasa
pasa que las empresas y en colegios
inventan manuales para recibir a los
diferentes como por ejemplo el signo de
down
para que sepas cómo relacionarse
adecuadamente con los norte daremos
algunos tips
pueden presentar resistencia al cambio
levanten la mano cuando usted le guste
los cambios
los que no levantaron la mano tendrán
algo de síndrome de dawn
al principio después les pueden costar
integrarse a su nuevo trabajo pero ojo
con el tiempo se adaptan
a todos los que integran los nuevos
trabajos no solamente las personas con
síndrome de down a todo nos cuesta
también integrarnos en un grupo de
amigos
cuando ya empezaron a estudiar
en distintas cosas me imagino si alguien
es psicólogo
cuando empezaron a estudiar en
psicología no imaginan que le costó
integrarse
son tan cariñosos responsables todos
aquí también se refuerza del mito del
que somos todos ágil y tos
y este mito también es uno de los
principales
pero yo les quiero decir y aquí en la
base está en la familia en las creencias
y en las experiencias
dios sabe cuándo y en dónde pero
nosotros aquí estamos en la tierra
les cuesta aprender tienen mala memoria
y la fábula que les conté antes
les cuesta mantener la atención en
tiempos prolongados apuesto que todo
usted ya está empezando en el coffee
break
apuesto a que en el trabajo se distraen
fácilmente viendo
cuántos likes tienen en su publicación
en instagram
o en twitter
aquí quiero recalcar que a todos nos
cuesta mantener la atención
no solamente a las personas con síndrome
de dawn
son detalles estás al terminar una tarea
no está intentando encuestas
se la gente intenta vincularse con y sin
humedad obtendrá una relación
discapacitada claro que se vincula con
el diagnóstico te va a costar eso tenlo
por seguro pero primero hay que ver la
persona ante todo
conocerla acercarte a ella creer en ella
y ya aprende de ti y tú no aprendes de
ella y ahí está el valor de la
diferencia
estoy aquí porque hay mucha gente que se
avergüenzan de sus diferencias sea cual
sea yo creo que ser diferente es un
valor
y me siento orgullosa de estar
representando a la mujer chilena con
síndrome de dawn para deslumbrar lo como
diferencia para que ustedes empoderen de
la suya
en resumen es verdad la historia de las
mujeres no ha sido fácil pero para
nosotras las mujeres con síndrome de
dawn personas
es muy difícil
es más difícil
porque aún aún seguimos luchando
por el derecho de ser educadas en
igualdad de oportunidades
y porque la historia ni siquiera nos ha
dado la oportunidad de ejercer nuestros
derechos de ser madres los dueños de
casa
y es más en muchos países se lo están
quitando el derecho a la vida
y aquí está el rol que cumplen ustedes
como viendo a la persona no al
diagnóstico porque el diagnóstico no ven
los médicos
siendo agentes activos
de cambio
dejándolo miedo a un lado
irma lentos y en vez de tomar el auto
tomen una bicicleta pues más caminen
para ver lo maravilloso que este mundo
siendo más flexibles más respetuosos con
todos porque todos todos somos
diferentes no solamente las personas con
síndrome de dawn
y aquí les tengo la última pregunta
cuando levante la mano cuando ustedes
piensan que yo tengo
síndrome de down
lo que levantaron la mano están
profundamente equivocados
porque en todas mis células están
felizmente afectadas con mi síndrome de
dawn
y lo que yo he tenido son oportunidades
todas las personas deberíamos tener
muchas oportunidades no solamente en las
obras las personas con síndrome de dawn
y me siento muy orgullosa con mi
síndrome
este mundo lo transformó yo lo necesito
a ustedes ustedes son los que
transforman
pero me necesitan a mí y ahí está el
valor de la diferencia
este este es el valor de la diferencia
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]